والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
العقيد تان كهفاي عن معارضتي بلاده
الشديده لتدخل حلف الناتو في شؤون اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ مشيرا الى ان الحلف يستخدم
ما يزعم انها تحديات تفرضها الصين كذريعه
لانشاء نسخه اسيويه من حلف شمال الاطلسي
وفق تعبيره
ومن تنجح نعرض بشده تدخل النيتو في شؤون
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ من خلال ما يسمى تحدي
الصين وانشاء نسخه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ من
النيتو في السنوات الاخيره تجاوز الحلف
باستمرار مناطق ومجالات الدفاع التقليديه
ساعيا الى تعزيز العلاقات الامنيه
العسكريه مع دول اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
واثاره التناقضات والخلافات والدعوه الى
المواجهه بين المعسكرات وفرض تحديات
حقيقيه على المنطقه وعلى السلام
والاستقرار العالميين